Um, yeah, you got the guns going. We all see them Chrissy say again,
I saw you're flexing now in that, take that, check it out. No,
no know what happened. I got to try some pot, man. Dude, you're crushing it.
I got to chill through the air conditioner and if maybe fled up,
but then I did look out, I look, tried to look at my tattoo, which looks like.
What is, what does it say? There's a scripture. This one, this one's my name,
my neighborhood on my arm. It says established 1984. The was born stupid.
Then I have scripture on my arm. I got a cross on my back.
I look like I'm fighting in a Catholic crusade that doesn't exist yet.
He looks like Robert de Niro from Cape fear. Yeah, it's stupid. He's got,
he's got like scriptures all over.
You guys are really big on your neighborhoods. Yeah. We love the neighborhoods.
I moved out of it immediately. And what's funny is, is all it is,
is nothing but horrific stories about how it was and what happened.
But like everybody, I respect that
of the dysfunction that you guys are, the, the Bay Ridge boys.
Now we're the favorite. Yeah. We made it even more local.
We got into show business to make, go even more local.
Like what can we think of the most obscure neighborhood?
How about Bay Ridge Brooklyn. There you go. Bill.
Did your friend who passed away? Did he pass away from COVID? No. No,
that sucks. It sucks to die during a pandemic, as something else.
That's not the disease. It's like dying on nine 11, but you weren't in the bill.
You got hit by a car. Yeah. Yeah. You don't,
you definitely don't get the big press release. Uh, no,
what it is is without getting totally into the deal. It's just when,
uh, you know, you start paying for your sins,
but yeah, I would suggest all of you guys, especially you Yannis,
I don't know. You just started sitting there sagging with that depressed.
Look on your face. You got a lot of weight, a lot of weight between your ears.
I would definitely go to a house. And uh, and between his lately,
I've gotten really fat recently bill. But, um,
I am envious that the fact that you guys got to be in show business,
stay where you're from. And um, you know,
still be able to go to the teams you want to see,
but that's also why new Yorkers are such meatheads is you guys never leave.
And your perspective of the world is like literally 20 blocks. Yeah.
It's just like, Oh, look at the skyline. Look at Phil. This is amazing.
And then when you go elsewhere, you act like you're not uncomfortable.
You act like it's just a piece of and you're above it.
But the reality is the second you guys get away from your favorite place to buy
your kicks and your pizza. You get horrifically uncomfortable.
Oh, I love going to LA. I appreciate the size. Now I roll around in California.
I go to the leftover here. We got a fire. That's on fire over there.
So that whole block Theo, Yonis fire over here,
those Mexicans right there,
they're working over there for than minimum wage over there.
Uh, there's water being piped in another state over there.
This place shouldn't be here. Well, none of us should be here.
We stole the country on us. I know. What about New York?
You can't do that in New York. I hang out with you in New York Yannis.
You're like over here, I got shot. This is where I saw a homeless guy. Take a.
And you want to talk about illegal aliens.
You don't have any of those in New York. That's got out of there.
And that's why I'm living in New Hampshire now, and country away from you, man.
They're taking my country. You're not going to do it. I got myself a gun.
I'm a gun owner coming, get some, anything comes up there, Hill I'm shooting it.
So yes, you got such a diarrhea of the mouth.
When you buy a gun.
The last thing you do is go on the podcast and let people know that when they go
in there at your house, that they need to be strapped to
literally read your playbook. You dummy, but book bill, if you're depressed,
when you come to do your show in Connecticut, can you please meet up with us?
Because we are the cure for depression. take you on a ferry ride.
You will set sail with you. We'll take you to some museums. We'll prance around,
get some ice cream and get cute and drink some smoothies and put a
smile on that sound. I would do that in a second,
but Yannis, I know you after the smoothie and the sugar rush ends.
I know as, as Chris says, Yonnie long days comes in now,
but he keeps forgetting what he's saying. One of my favorite clips,
I saw your show, which I absolutely love. I think you guys are superstars, man.
People watching this, you got to check these guys out. Um,
I was watching this clip,
some guy talking about COVID and he was talking about the things,
bad things that were happening and Yannis was just stoking the fires guys like,
well, he knows gonna be hospital beds filled is going to be blah, blah, blah,
blah. And then Yon is just goes riding in the streets.
And the guys like riding in the streets. And I literally, I swiped past it.
It's like, I don't want to listen to this. Yeah. You know,
I hate that. I'm right. So much. I avoid, um, uh,
that train of thought because I know how I'm wired and I'm paranoid. And I,
I can't listen to that the same way.
Like I avoid a lot of discussions with parents
when they get into that hysteria. Like,
have you got your kid into a private school yet? You gotta do this.
Are they doing puzzles? If they're not doing puzzles, people are saying, blah,
blah, blah. I just, I just walk away. So yeah.
I on the ride, I'd get the smoothie. I'd give,
I'd give Chrissy to nod.
And then I would slowly just back away and I don't even give a what subway line
it was on and which way it was going.
I go down those stairs and I would get on it and then just get away from
you. Yeah. One of those things where it's like, yeah,
I feel like I'm trans today. What? Like, like,
am I a bad person? Now? If I'm like, Hey today I feel trans.
And that's what I want to go with.
But that tomorrow I don't are you shaming me by telling me, Hey, yesterday,
you want it to be transit today. You don't like,
I just feel like everything's a free for all now on what you can. And can't say,
it's like, yeah, you know what? Today would bill Burr.
I want it to go trans and that's I felt right. And maybe tomorrow I will.
No, no nobody's saying you can't go trans. I don't know.
I didn't know where that came from. Well, I'm gonna go cut my Dick off.
Stop with all the old country horse. You,
you are 100% of this country. You're out of this soil.
That that's, that's what you are. I am, I am.
I am searching for an identity and I can tell you right now,
you don't get that fatty in Greek food.
Can you argue that you are eating American poison? That is what you are eating.
Yeah. I got to get my tongue, man. You got, you got maybe a D cop going there.
Yeah. I'm in the stage
and I'm telling them it's going to get it's.
I could go one or two ways when the baby's born,
either something will kick in is genetic coding will kick in and say,
I got to lose the weight for this baby and do this or that. Or it's just,
he's going to be so exhausted. Especially those first couple of years that,
I mean, we get into a real, I mean,
I'm talking about a 400 pound situation where I'll just get a
slab bacon off his on the Patrion all day.
Yeah,
definitely has the potential to become a big boy. You see him?
He's a, he's one of those in-shape guys, but you can also see,
you can see the fatty within, I'm going to breakfast up on you now. Yeah.
I mean, as versus see how I eat,
he actually says he's actually cannot believe that I have not blown out fully,
by the way I eat.
He's actually said that I sometimes put on displays that rival like Bobby Kelly
displays of eating. There you go. All right guys. Thank you so much.
I hope to see you soon when this is over,
we really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate and review us. Subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boards,
where things get really wild.